madame monsieur bonsoir voici les titres
de ce journal l'actualité du jour est
bien sûr dominée par la mort du roi du
maroc hassan ii
il régnait depuis 1961 son fils le
deuxième de ses cinq enfants va lui
succéder sous le nom de mohamed 6 la
succession est difficile après des
années de plomb le roi du maroc avait
fait le pari d'une transition
démocratique incontestable ouvriers de
la paix au proche orient
hassan ii monarque absolu et commandeur
des croyants laisse un pays écartelé
entre féodalité modernité ses obsèques
auront lieu dimanche en présence de
nombreux chefs d'état dans ce journal en
direct shimon pérès selon l'ancien
premier ministre israélien et maurice
druon de l'académie française
tous nos amis du roi du maroc nous
sommes au kosovo 14 paysans serbes ont
été assassinés au sud de pristina le
tour de france le contre la montre du
jour a été remportée comme prévu par le
maillot jaune armstrong
avec seulement neuf secondes d'avancé
sur le suisse alex joue le deuxième de
l'étape 30 millions de marocains sont
entrés vendredi soir après l'annoncé du
décès d'hassan ii des suites cardiaque
d'une affection pulmonaire dans une
période de deuil de 40 jours
depuis hier soir les habitants de rabat
se rendre au palais royal
ailleurs dans la ville l'activité semble
suspendu pascal golomer olivier robert
ils n'étaient que quelques dizaines ce
matin cette fois ils sont plusieurs
milliers devant la porte des
ambassadeurs
la porte principale d'accès au palais
royal de rabat là où propose depuis hier
soir la dépouille d'hassan ii plusieurs
milliers de marocains de tous les âges
venus pour un dernier hommage à leur
souverain beaucoup de prières
beaucoup de larmes aussi et les mêmes
mots qui reviennent sans cesse nous
avons perdu vraiment un autre gang
pierre qui a donné beaucoup au maroc il
est mis au point au monde islamique
mon général c'est un frère c'est un
parent n'y aura jamais de 2 m2 nous
l'aimons nous l'aimons beaucoup tout
l'après midi les jeunes sont venus
manifester leur dévouement au roi
jusqu'au sacrifice dit steve décrit dans
une ville en deuil avec drapeaux en
berne à quelques centaines de mètres de
là les vieilles rues de la médina
d'ordinaire si animé sont silencieuses
les boutiques n'ont pas levé leur rideau
de fer
l'émotion toujours et la tristesse
on a perdu quelque chose de
tout ce qui est sacrément nôtre
culture montre
notre éducation dit vous voyez comme ça
on est sûr que vous voyez des ongs et
les grandes lignes si la foule viendra à
nouveau ici demain cette fois pour
accompagner son roi jusqu'à sa dernière
demeure
passée l'émotion et le deuil il sera
temps alors pour les marocains de
s'interroger sur le bilan en instillant
règne et sur l'enjeu de la succession
la télévision marocaine a rapidement
annoncé en fin d'après midi vendredi la
mort du souverain plus tard dans la
soirée le nouveau roi mohamed6 a reçu
l'allégeance des principaux dignitaires
du régime notamment des religieux le
souverain du maroc est en effet la
personnalité la plus prestigieuse de
l'islam sunnite comme descendants du
prophète mahomet il le commandeur des
croyants
maryse burgot le présentateur de la
télévision marocaine a beaucoup de mal à
contenir son émotion
il est près de 20 heures trente hier
soir tous les programmes vient d'être
interrompu la diffusion de versets du
coran alerte les téléspectateurs d'un
drame imminent
quelques minutes plus tard le prince
héritier sidi mohamed vient exhorté son
peuple à rester calme et patient dans la
douleur
mon père sa majesté le roi hassan
que dieu bénisse son âme a succombé à
une crise cardiaque à 16h30
suite à des complications qui n'ont pas
pu être prêté dès l'annoncé officielle
du décès plusieurs centaines de
personnes viennent d'exprimer leur
affliction devant le palais royal où
repose le corps du doyen des chefs
d'état africains 29 millions de sujets
marocains s'apprête à respecter le deuil
national de 40 jours décrétée sur tout
le territoire
hassan ii vient de disparaître à l'âge
de 70 ans après 38 ans de règne et déjà
à l'intérieur du palais le fils aîné du
roi s'apprête à monter sur le trône
dans quelques minutes sidi mohamed
deviendra mohamed6 roi du maroc
l'intronisation du prince se déroule
selon un protocole emprunté aux règles
traditionnelles du royaume
il faut signer un serment d' allégeance
au roi
chaque dignitaires religieux chaque haut
responsable du gouvernement ou de
l'armée s'exécute et baise l'épaule ou
la main du souverain
ces sommes ont été depuis longtemps
préparée à l'arrivée de mohamed 6 mai
seuls l'histoire dira quelle manière de
gouverner
hassan ii a enseigné à s'occuper en
attendant ce soir devant le palais royal
à rabat ce nouveau voix de 36 ans est
acclamée par la foule
cet après midi justement rabat philippe
rochot et philippe naudy ont pu
rencontrer andré azoulay un homme
d'affaires issu de la communauté juive
marocaine et conseiller à la cour du roi
ils ont évoqué avec lui la transition
apparemment tranquille qui se met en
place
le nouveau souverain marocain mohamed 6
à l'occasion du dernier ramadan au début
de l'année encore dans l'ombre de la san
de il voulait montrer là que sa
principale préoccupation était le sort
des pauvres mais le fossé qui les sépare
des riches est resté très profonds au
maroc un souverain très discret le
principe dit mohamed s'était réservé les
dossiers sociaux durant le règne de son
père
à présent qu'il est roi ce souverain de
36 ans devra montrer qu'il a des
solutions
- médecis s'installe donc ici à la tête
de ce palais royal qui a vécu tant de
drames et de complot mais l'homme qui
fut pendant dix ans le conseiller du roi
hassan ii andré azoulay y voit plutôt la
continuité d'une politique et non pas
l'arrêt d'un processus de
démocratisation
le maroc de façon très profonde
son trait
réfléchis
construit une nation une société une
façon d'être et de vivre ce pays ou dans
le cadre d'une monarchie
constitutionnelle parlementaire toute
liberté bien sûr sont là et s'exerce
normalement et ce projet politique est
nourri par une stratégie économique qui
crée de la richesse régulièrement des
richesses qui sont encore loin de
profiter à tous mais mohamed 6 me
relever dit on le défi de la
mondialisation
son père l'envoyait déjà côtoyé les
grands de ce monde mais son rôle si
effacé durant à rennes paternelle de 30
ans aussi personnaliser marque sans
doute ses limites alors que sa tâche
sera immense
les véhicules marocain auquel le maroc a
répondu celui du de l'accélération et la
consolidation de sa croissance et son
développement notre vraie des fils de
créer de plus en plus d'emplois notre
défi c'est de donner une réponse de plus
en plus substantiels à tous ces jeunes
qui a il formé sur ma chaise en bois
mais dans les rues de rabat ce soir ça
n'était pas le nom de mohamed 6 que l'on
attendait c'était toujours celui du roi
hassan ii mais avec l'un ou l'autre le
maroc montre de toute façon qu'il reste
attaché à la royauté avec nous en direct
philippe rochot philippe vous êtes à
rabat et pour l'instant on sait très peu
de choses sur le nouveau roi mohamed6
les les informations qu'ils concernent
sont très contradictoires au fait oui
c'est vrai qu'il s'est passé peut
manifester mais vous voyez là nous
sommes à quelques pas du mausolée où le
roi hassan ii sera enterré demain et
finalement les conversations commencent
un peu à fuser autour de mohamed cissé
sa personnalité effectivement est très
controversé certains disent que c'est un
peu le le nouveau juan carlos pour le
maroc
d'autres disent que c'est un personnage
imbu de lui même il faudra attendre sans
doute quelques mois pour le voir à
l'exercice du pouvoir est jugé ainsi de
sa personnalité
maintenant il reste que il a accepté ce
défi économique qui est lancée au maroc
vous savez que en plus du problème des
pauvres il ay ay si quelque chose comme
plus de 55% d'illettrés il y à chaque
jour des dizaines de marocains qui
tentent de passer le détroit de
gibraltar pour aller en europe et sous
là aussi ça fait partie du défi
maintenant il entend sans doute
continuer la politique avait mené jusque
là le roi hassan ii et qui était un
petit peu de
c'est le monde économique et notamment
de construire un barrage par année comme
on disait chaque fois pour la politique
économique du roi hassan ii après
l'entretien vous avez eue avec andres b
tout à l'heure est ce que quelqu'un est
ce qu'on peut dire de des pistes
économiques sur lesquels va continuer le
maroc ou sur lesquels il peut s'engager
maintenant écouter le maroc finalement
les gens nous disaient est très fier
d'avoir réussi un meilleur résultat
économique que l'algérie qui elle avait
le avait le pétrole donc les marocains
n'entendent pas trouvé de changement
fondamental c'est un pays qui reste
toujours basé bien sûr sur l'agriculture
et qui continuera à l'être maintenant le
nouveau roi est prêt à relever le défi
de la mondialisation il se rendra très
prochainement en europe et puis
finalement le maroc frappe lui aussi à
la porte de l'union européenne et il
entend bien qu'on lui réponde pour
éviter précisément ces dizaines de gens
de jeunes désespérés qui essaye de
passer le détroit de gibraltar pour se
rendre sur notre continent
merci philippe rochot vous êtes en
direct de rabat et vous êtes l'une l'un
de nos envoyés spéciaux sur place on
ajoutera que le roi du maroc possède de
l'une des grandes fortunes de la planète
télé notamment investi dans la banque
l'agroalimentaire ou les médias
si le bilan de ce long règne et
controversé il est un domaine où hassan
2 diplomate habile a su laisser une
empreinte salué unanimement c'est celui
du rapprochement israélo arabe à fès en
1982 avait notamment été entériné un
plan de paix prévoyant la reconnaissance
d'israël par les états arabes contre une
restitution des territoires occupés par
l'état hébreu
hassan 2 et le proche orient charles
enderlin un avion israélien sur une
piste d'atterrissage marocaines ces
images volées sont les seules qui
existent de la première visite semi
officielle d'un chef de gouvernement
israélien au maroc
c'était en juillet 1986 et race and de
voulait par ce geste encourager et aider
son ami shimon peres alors premier
ministre de fait aucun dirigeant arabe
n'a autant le vrai pour un rapprochement
avec israël
déjà en 1958 prince héritier il avait
présidé à florence la première
conférence sur la paix au proche orient
nous avons pour la première fois réussi
à réunir des arabes au niveau le plus
important à st
de façon plus des délégations d'egypte
du liban de syrie d'algérie tunisie et
bien sûr du maroc
ça a été la première fois qu'il ya eu
une réunion israélo arabe
à partir de là que le courant de
sympathie à plus lentement lentement
comme lentement se faire et lorsque le
19 novembre 1977 l'avion d'anouar el
sadate s'est posé sur l'aéroport de
tel-aviv
seuls quelques chefs de services
spéciaux savait que cette visite
historique a été précédée par des
entretiens secrets au maroc entre
l'israélien moshe dayal ra santo rami le
vice-premier ministre égyptien
la première paix au proche orient a
commencé dans le bureau de race and 2
plus tard il fut un intermédiaire un
médiateur entre israël et l'olp et entre
itzhak rabin et yasser arafat et pour
les juifs du maroc à s'installer en
israël c'est ptet fondamentales prévues
du maroc sont reconnaissants sont
reconnaissants à 5,2 et à son père et en
plus ils ont énormément de plaisir à
visiter leur pays d'origine et à
s'imprégner de vous de l'ambiance dans
laquelle ils ont vécu ou bien leurs
parents
le hasard a voulu que hier après midi au
moment où outre hassan ii et qui
transporte
moore à l'hôpital en israël shimon peres
inauguré ce bâtiment luxueux offert par
le souverain chérifien
la première chambre de commerce israélo
marocaine justement shimon peres vous
êtes en direct avec nous de tel-aviv
monsieur le premier ministre merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation je sais
que vous partez dans quelques heures
pour rabat pour assister aux obsèques
d'hassan ii le processus de paix au
proche orient a perdu deux de ses
partisans récemment avec hussein de
jordanie et hier avec hassan 2 du roi du
maroc vous dit qu'il était visionnaire
pourquoi utiliser ce qualificatif
parce qu'elle était la première qui
demandait au monde arabe reconnaît
israël et demandé à israël reconnaît les
alpes est l'étaient les premières qui a
offert son pays pour une rencontre
entend à présent en israël et en égypte
sienne ils étaient les premières
organisées qui organise une conférence
économique sans pareil à casablanca avec
presque et 3000 personnes moitié et
l'air rom officielle et les autres les g
messieurs des affaires et ils
travaillent sans arêtes
savez-vous c'était un homme qui combat
nizet les grandes cultures françaises
avec les longues traditions nous les
mandalas moyen-orient elle était la
première parmi les arabes qui comprend
profonde à mot les problèmes des mondes
juive qu'il cherchait rénové encore une
fois l'âge des eaux entre les musulmans
elle jouit alors justement monsieur
shimon peres com est-ce que vous
expliquer cette considération kvs end
pour les juifs marocains en particulier
pour l'état d'israël puis plus
généralement c'est un fait historique
pas seulement politique et le pensait
que la meilleur temps dans la moyenne à
rien était
les reconnaissances entre les
civilisations d oise avec la
civilisation de mohammad et le monde
chrétien
monsieur monsieur perez que hassan ii et
était un ami pour vous quels souvenirs
vous laisse l'homme au sahara est créé
terriblement un homme avec une culture
exceptionnelle avec un chalet au
personal encore une fois très spécial
chaque fois que j'ai fermé les yeux nous
avons discuté pendant les nuits
quelles sont les chances pour créer une
nouvelle chance pour les jeunes un
martien de la briane orioles il était
presque et comment pensent si vous
voulez pour nous tous il parle avec
beaucoup de chaleur sur son expérience
avec le juif et le mahdi qui la femme
qui a donné lui les lier était aussi une
femme juif athée est la paix tél sinfra
il a versé un fils le même âge des rois
elle m'a dit c'était mon frère pas
seulement le frère d'hélène ans est le
frère d'un mot merci monsieur shimon
peres d'avoir été notre invité dans ce
journal
hassan ii été fait roi à l'âge de 32 ans
il avait été associé très tôt par son
père mohamed 5 à la conduite des
affaires un aussi long règne fait des
ennemis
il a échappé à plusieurs attentats ses
partisans comme ses adversaires
d'ailleurs le surnommer le grand
survivants plus soucieux du rayonnement
de son pays que de social hassan ii
comme monarque comme chefs religieux
avaient su contenir les mouvements
intégristes et faire l'unité nationale
sur le sahara occidental
même si ce dossier n'est pas réglé
bernard lebrun
les traits tirés le visage émacié par la
fatigue et la maladie il était tout de
même venu le hasard aura voulu que le
roi hassan 2 face à paris il ya dix
jours seulement
l'une de ses dernières apparitions
publiques accompagné de sa garde royale
des finances sur les champs elysées
presque une revanche de l'histoire
un hommage en tous les cas en guise
d'adieu à l'ancienne puissance coloniale
qui aurait prédit de 3 mars 1961 que le
petit roi comme on l'appelait alors
régnerait durant 38 ans sur le royaume
chérifien
exilé en corse puis à madagascar à la
fin du protectorat le prince moulay
hassan achève ses études de droit à
bordeaux
héritier de mohamed 5 il a 32 ans quand
il accède au trône
cinq années seulement après
l'indépendance descendant du prophète
commandant des croyants ils acceptent la
tradition mais impose sa marque en
modernisant la monarchie tout en prônant
un islam modéré et une cohabitation avec
la communauté juive du pays
hassan ii où la passion du pouvoir peu
d'amour ont suscité autant de débats
passionnés ou de sentiments
contradictoires que le roi du maroc
on a écrit que les attentats contre lui
lui avait rapidement enlevé ses
illusions sur la nature humaine
son règne est notamment marquée par deux
tentatives avortées de coup d'état
il échappe de peu à la fusillade du
palais skhirat en 1971
et puis à l'attack de son boeing en 1972
par les avions de chasse de sa propre
arme miracle sa reprise en main des
troupes sera impitoyable l'avion se pose
et le souverain et trace dans l'oeuf le
l'armée marocaine il va lui trouver une
mission pour des années en novembre 1975
hassan ii organise la marche verte dans
le désert qui permet au maroc de
récupérer le sahara occidental alors
sous domination espagnole l'intégrité
territoriale du maroc où leurs rêves
inaboutis d'un nationalisme triomphant
reste la grande idée politique qui
devait faire du peuple marocain un seul
bloc autour du roi
sur le plan social on opposera longtemps
après sa mort le protocole et le faste
luxueux du palais royal d'hassan 2 au
niveau de vie des laissés-pour-compte de
la modernisation du pays
les dernières émeutes de décembre 1990
déclenchée par l'augmentation du coût de
la vie soutenus par les étudiants
islamistes secoue la classe politique en
1998 pour dit-on alors garantir la
pérennité du système monarchique hassan
2 provoque la première alternance depuis
l'indépendance il choisit pour premier
ministre abderrahmane youssoufi anciens
opposants condamnés à 15 ans d'exil et
leader de l'ugt sfp le parti socialiste
marocain le roi avait un dernier rêve
géopolitique celui ci dont il avait fait
une affaire personnelle
depuis des années ils rêvaient de
creuser un tunnel sous le détroit de
gibraltar véritable cimetière marin des
immigrés clandestins pour réunir le
maroc à l'espagne mais surtout pour
accrocher deux continents l'afrique à
l'europe parce que son royaume il le
voulait tel un pont entre l'orient et
l'occident de bill clinton qui se dit
profondément attristé à yasser arafat
qui parle d'une catastrophe pour le
peuple palestinien l'hommage est unanime
les deux hommes assisteront d'ailleurs
aux obsèques comme le premier ministre
israélien ehud barak
jacques chirac y courte lui son voyage
en afrique et son escale camerounaise
pour se rendre à rabat réaction du chef
de l'état français et du premier
ministre lionel jospin au décès d'hassan
ii le roi du maroc et est aujourd'hui un
ami de la france c'est une immense peine
que j'éprouve à la suite du départ de sa
majesté hassan ii roi du maroc
et j'adresse au roi mohamed 6 à tous les
chiens au peuple marocain tout entier
mes condoléances très affectueuse et
celle de la france c'est vraiment un ami
de notre pays un amoureux de notre
culture qui vient de disparaître avec le
roi hassan ii je pense naturellement à
la peine des marocains je pense aussi
d'ailleurs à la peine des marocains qui
vivent dans notre pays et qui sont
nombreux cela dit les relations entre
paris et rabat n'ont pas toujours été au
beau fixe au moment de l'affairé ben
barka du nom de cet opposant marocain
assassiné après avoir été enlevé à paris
le général de gaulle avait jugé
l'affairé inadmissible insoutenable et
inacceptable de fait il y a un devoir
d'inventaire de la monarchie chérifienne
le chemin vers la démocratie symbolisée
par la nomination d'un premier ministre
socialiste est récent le maroc a connu
ses années noires
le dossier des droits de l'homme restent
ouverts hervé brusini derrière les
forteresses de l'histoire marocaine
le pays possède d'autres muraille celle
des prisons en pleine capitale à rabat
ici au beau milieu d'un cimetière à
kénitra ils étaient 120 prisonniers
politiques condamnés à 10 20 30 ans pour
appartenance à un parti d'opposition
ou tout simplement pour avoir distribué
des tracts par deux fois ces images au
début des années 80 ont été déprogrammés
à la télévision française
les relations franco marocaines avaient
aussi cet influent cela ne fait il
interviewait clandestinement les
prisonniers parler clairement de torture
toutes les formes de torture
possible ce que depuis quelques mois
plus tard enfin leur libération était
annoncé pourtant officiellement il
n'existait pas le silence comme
technique de gouvernement
telle était la face sombre du pouvoir de
hassan ii en octobre 65 par exemple un
opposant marocain est enlevée ici en
plein paris mehdi ben barka disparaît
des truands des barbus des policiers
français participent à l'opération
montée par le général oufkir la sphère
reste encore aujourd'hui une énigme un
silence de plus au début des années 90
le silence se brise lentement abraham
serfaty militants politiques d'extrême
gauche est enfin libre après 17 années
passées derrière les barreaux
il s'est lui aussi le silence qui pèse
sur cette cité des emmurés vivants
tazmamart une prison en plein désert
les gradés de l'armée impliqués dans des
complots ils sont reclus comme des
animaux seuls quelques messages des
dessins font connaître au monde
l'existence de ce lieu tenu au secret
absolu parfois disait hassan ii le
prophète qui était un homme doux pouvait
avoir ses colères et la colère fut
terrible à l'égard des enfants du
général oufkir maria par exemple est
resté vain en détention aujourd'hui il
est encore préoccupé par le sort des
détenus
la première chose auquel j'ai pensé je
pense hélas ce sont toujours enfermés
j'étais pas du tout personnel moi je
suis libre j'ai combattu pour avoir ma
liberté je suis sûr que les personnes
enfermées actuellement au maroc
lorsqu'ils ont appris la mort d'hassan
ii n'ont pensé qu'à une seule chose
peut-être à leur liberté
une loi sur la décentralisation la
liberté de la presse une commission des
droits de l'homme
peu à peu la face sombre du pouvoir
s'est éclairci peu à peu si le régime a
commencé d'indemniser les victimes il se
refuse pour l'instant à juger les
anciens tortionnaires
et puis il y à d'autres zones d'ombré on
peut noter qu'en 1994 dans un rapport
confidentiel commandé par l'union
européenne à l'observatoire géopolitique
des drogues
plusieurs hauts représentants ou des
proches du pouvoir avait été mise en
cause dans la filière d'exportation du
cannabis du maroc vers l'europe
celles ci représentant la première
source de devises du pays
comme le disait ce matin la fille du
général oufkir malika mise à l'isolément
puis assigné elle aussi à résidence
pendant des années
l'heure n'est pas aux règlements de
compte les marocains semblent réunies
aujourd'hui par ce deuil
cette fascination pour la royauté même
chez les opposants farouches semble
paradoxal écoutez ce qu'en dit hamid
berrada journalistes marocains à jeune
afrique puis à tv5
il a eu à subir pendant des années la
répression du régime nous n'avons pas
les mêmes relations avec le pouvoir
quand vous avez en europe pour vous le
pouvoir est un peu lointain il
il est là pour faire un certain nombre
de boulot et en général surtout en
france en est vis-à-vis de lui grincheux
revendicateurs râleurs nous avons en
pays musulman pays arabes
nous avons des rapports de pouvoir que
jouent les rapports d'adhésion sont les
rapports de famille je sais c'est
quelqu'un qui fait partie de notre vie
et participer contre hassan ii à un
complot pour l'éliminer physiquement
devait le tuer d'autres vies qu'il y ait
une répression après dés ce que nous
allions faire qui n'avions commencé à
faire c'est de bonne guerre mais en a
retenu c'est de bonne guerre aussi quand
progressait à l'opinion internationale
que l'aspect le plus positif de gestion
des démocrates et notre adversaire
arrêtez sanguinaire ferro par exemple
oui même qui avait souffert de cette
répression
j'suis pas qu'ils n'ont souffert j'étais
condamné à mort puis à recaser le projet
longuement
oui j exilés et exilé pendant une
quinzaine d'années et aujourd'hui vous
ressentez cette tristesse gerfaut qui
depuis longtemps
vive l'anarchie j'ai fait mon marché des
space ou compte pour les marocains
d'état et la monarchie mais les
monarchies mois les archaïsmes
voilà en tout cas des propos qui pose la
question de la notion d'état de droit
avec maintenant direct de rabat maurice
druon le secrétaire perpétuel de
l'académie française monsieur mohammed-v
avait conseillé à son fils hassan ii
d'aller vous voir pour apprendre alors
j'aimerais vous demander maintenant ce
que vous lui avez appris et quel
jugement ou en tout cas ce que vous
retenez de celui qui est devenu votre
ami je ne sais pas s'ils y est
le roi mohamed 5 a envoyé son fils
auprès de moi pour apprendre ce que je
sais c'est que j'ai rencontré hassan ii
alors prince héritier en 1955 quand il
revenait quand il revenait de madagascar
ou l'idiotie d'un gouvernement français
avait envoyé son père en exil et
injecter du petit nombre de semer avec
edgar faure avec françois mauriac
j'envisage et qui est militait pour le
rétablissement du sultan sur son trône
et pour l'indépendance du maroc parce
que c'était à la fois la justice et la
nécessité j'ai été frappé mais frappé
par la maturité de ce jeune homme qui
n'avait que 25 ans et qui est ne faisait
aucune récrimination quillet n'avait pas
de reproche envers la france mais qui ne
pensaient qu'à l'avenir à l'avenir de
son pays à la vie et à l'avenir des
relations avec la france qui l'a
toujours voulu garder
il se souvenait d'avoir eu des
professeurs français ils avaient été mis
cheap à bord de la jeanne d'arc
il avait pris ses diplômes à bordeaux
vous savez à mon âge on ne peut pas
avoir d' amitié
pour un homme pour qu'il en est pas à la
fois de l'estimé de l'admiration morisod
on se sent bien votre amitié alors je
voulais vous poser une dernière question
jeudi tout à l'heure qu'on savait en
fait peu de choses du nouveau roi
mohamed6 que les informations sur lui
était relativement contradictoires et
que les avis étaient partagés
que pouvez vous nous dire de ce jeune
roi jeune roi nous surprendra je le
pense je le connais depuis son enfance
j'ai voyagé avec lui son père en
certains cas me l'a confié j'ai il est
extrêmement réservés il a énormément de
dignité il est d'un tempérament qui
rappellera à mon avis celui de son grand
père mohammed-v qui fûtes grand roi
comme son fils l'un le roi de
l'indépendance l'autre le roi du
développement et de l'émergence du maroc
merci maurice druon de nous avoir livré
votre perception des choses
voyons maintenant les réactions de la
communauté marocaine à paris géraldine
d'albas morenas junia trias
elles n'ont pas dormi trop de larmes
trop de prière ce matin la première
heure elles sont toutes venues ici au
consulat du maroc les unes après les
autres elles se sont succédé devant les
livres de condoléances pour écrire à
leur wild talus de l'énergie gérer toute
la famille royale marocaine
elles attendent elles préfèrent rester
là qu'être seule chez elle pour partager
cette journée de deuil se soutenir quand
la douleur est trop forte
on aurait alors qu'une seule issue la
prière
et
moi
la religion musulmane des compères
enchère c'est la prière c'est le coran
mais on sait très bien que ce cher là il
est parti dans un lieu très très sain
encore beaucoup plus sain et qui sera
encore roi là où il voit à l'ambassade
du maroc mmm va et vient est toujours
latente plus d'une heure avant de
pouvoir écrire quelques lignes
pas de quoi les décourager depuis ce
matin plus de quatre mille marocains
sont venus ici rendre à leurs droits
un dernier hommage
voyons maintenant la suite de
l'actualité avec le kosovo le tribunal
pénal international vient d'ouvrir une
enquête 14 paysans serbes ont été tuées
par balles vendredi soir dans un village
du centre de la province
bernard kouchner l'administrateur de
l'onu a qualifié cette exécution d'actes
inhumains et gratuit les serbes accuse
les albanais et met en cause la force
multinationale de paix agnès vahramian
jean françois renaud c'était hier soir
vers 21h au bout de ce chemin il faisait
nuit
quatorze paysans serbe de ce village
achevé leurs travaux aux champs quand
des coups de feu ont éclaté
tous sont morts ils étaient sans armes
parmi les habitants pas de témoins
directs
ceux là sont en colère la kfor distille
ne sait de toute façon jamais soucier de
leur sécurité
quand on appelait la kfor pour qu'il
nous protège
il disait qu'il n'avait mis suffisamment
de véhicules ni à fait personnel
regardez maintenant ils sont au moins
une centaine ainsi il pense peut-être
qu'on va aller venger et attaquer les
albanais il y a deux mois les militaires
de l'alliance bombardaient l'armée
yougoslave leur armée alors comment
avoir confiance dans ses soldats perçu
comme l'occupant vous savez on restera
ici on attendra que les albanais nous
abattent et après peut-être qu'ils
seront contents l'épisode n'aurait pu
être qu'un banal fait divers au sortir
de la guerre
mais ces quatorze morts anéantissent les
efforts des nations unies pour établir
sécurité et multi ethnisme au kosovo
alci youtube et guillaume bernard
kouchner avons tenté de demander pardon
ainsi fallu supplier ces serbes de
rester il sait que la paix recul c'est
plus facile de reconstruire une maison
que de reconstruire une arme c'est plus
facile de regagner du terrain sur les
destructions que de regagner du terrain
dans la confiance et dans la source pas
dire fraternité la kfor affirme qu'elle
ne peut pas protéger chaque serbe et
aucune consigne n'existe pour que les
patrouilles soit plus présente dans leur
village les militaires de l'alliance
semble donc bien impuissant à réprimer
le
désir de vengeance des albanais en
france dans le massif des alpilles il
incendie qui a détruit 2000 hectares est
en passe d'être maîtrisé
c'est ce qu'annonce ce soir un
communiqué de la direction des pompiers
des bouches du rhône sur place frédéric
dupuy yann moines tuyaux à l'épaule pour
éviter le contact avec le sol
il faudrait en quelques minutes les
cendres pourtant détrempée sont encore
brûlante
cet après-midi le mistral est tombé 20
25 km heure l'occasion enfin pour les
pompiers de noyer la végétation encore
épargné pour éviter les reprises ils
sont toujours un millier sur le terrain
depuis 48 heures maintenant
il a passé la nuit dehors n'a pas encore
mangé l'a pas eue le tard r ce n'est pas
une punition des événements qui ont
voulu ça si l'incendié est stabilisé
pour l'instant la nuit dernière c'était
l'enfer l'ennemi le feu bien sûr des
flammes de plus de 30 mètres mais aussi
le vent qui rallume sans arrêt les
foyers des rafales à plus de 80
kilomètres heure les pompiers ne savent
plus où donner de la tête
comment la chaleur déjà aujourd'hui le
vent qui lui est très éprouvant pour
louvoyer
ceux prévus dans le combat comme ça la
pinède à griller toute la nuit
cet après-midi les canadairs ont repris
leur ballet la chaleur favorise les
départs d'isoler ch mais grâce à la
chute du vent ils ne sont plus
préoccupants les conditions telles
qu'elles sont nous va nous permettre
d'aborder la journée de la nuit et la
journée de demain avec grain de
confiance ce soir les dernières lisière
en flammes sont sous contrôle il ya
quelques minutes les pompiers
annonçaient la maîtrise totale du feu la
surveillance sera encore maintenue toute
la nuit s'ils restent deux mille
hectares de la vallée des bons le plus
saisissant paysage des alpilles réduit
en un océan de centre c'est en corse en
revanche qu'il ya des inquiétudes ce
soir une quinzaine d'incendiés ont été
signalés dans l'après-midi au sud de
ghisonaccia haute corse le vent forts
compliquent la tâche des pompiers les
enquêteurs estiment qu'il doit s'agir
d'un incendie criminel
à l'heure qu'il est une partie des
moyens aériens utilisés dans les
alpilles vols vers la corse
le dossier de la viande belges touchés
par une contamination à la dioxine je
vous rappelle que 60 à 80 milles tonnes
de viandes notamment le porc vont être
détruites
les autorités belges et c'est maintenant
de rassurer leurs partenaires étrangères
pour elle la viande de porc actuellement
exporté par la belgique est saine
cela dit sa traçabilité comme l'on dit
aujourd'hui laisse à désirer cyrille
devaud marianne masse
encore des soucis au rayon boucherie
après la crise de la vache folle le
pouls les belges à la dioxine
c'est maintenant la viande de porc qui
est montré du doigt certains animaux
élevés en belgique ont été contaminés à
la dioxine résultat lorsqu'il doit
choisir sa viande le consommateur ne
sait plus quoi penser
si on regarde tout tout ce qu'on mange
si on analyse tout vraiment on va plus
rien à manger froides il détaille
d'acheter français et pour tous soit
je sais pas parce que si c'est pas vrai
c'est pas toujours marquer enfin qu'il
dans les supermarchés devraient être
marqués ici on vend uniquement de la
viande de porc française et on
l'indiquent clairement sur l'emballage
c'est un choix aucune loi n'oblige une
telle mention d'origine
à partir du moment où l'origine france
n'est pas spécifié sur l'étiquette comme
nous le faisons rien ne vous garantit
que c'est du sport français
ça peut être du port belge pourquoi pas
car du port belge
il y en a en france l'embargo sur toutes
les viandes venus de belgique décidé
après la crise du poulet à la dioxine a
été levée pour le port le 6 juillet
dernier
depuis cette date le port belge peut à
nouveau passé la frontière avec un
certificat sanitaire
ce certificat france de bourthes l'a
reçue aujourd'hui même ses cochons
avaient mangé des graines suspectes
par précaution ils ont dû rester deux
mois en quarantaine nous avons dû faire
abattre deux truies et deux porcelets
nous les avons découpé et on a prélevé
de la grèce pour vérifier en laboratoire
s'il y avait de la dioxine
le résultat a été négatif les autorités
belges se veulent rassurantes
les contrôles se poursuivent dans les
800 élevage encore sous séquestre et les
interdictions d'exporter sont peu à peu
levé à pau les syndicats se gardent de
tout triomphalisme après l annonce par l
feu du retrait du plan de réorganisation
qui prévoyait 1300 suppressions
d'emplois cette décision met fin à une
grève qui dure depuis cent quatre jours
est à replacer dans le cadre des
négociations qui ont actuellement lieu
entre elf et total fina pour une fusion
éric perrin frédéric guérin tchèque le
chant de la victoire par la chorale de
l'intersyndicale
le coup de théâtre s'est produit ce
matin la direction d'elf paix à pau
convoque les syndicats pour leur
annoncer le retrait du plan de
performance qui prévoyait la suppression
de 1500 des 2800 emplois à la raison est
liée à l'eau peut en cours du groupe elf
aquitaine sur le groupe total qui fait
que les bases de l'étude qui avait
conduit au plan de performance fp risque
d'être dans quelques mois
totalement inadapté au contexte dans
lequel sera l'entreprise
cette victoire des grévistes est aussi
celle de toute une région qui s'est
immédiatement mobilisé un conflit très
longs sans trois jours et surtout unique
quant au procédé utilisé le blocage du
centre informatique du gros c'est la
première cyber grève aussi qu'un hacker
qui a marché c'est c'est quand même
extraordinaire de voir des cadres des
techniciens qui ont occupée jour et nuit
un centre informatique et qui ont pu
faire plier qu'un groupe comme le groupe
f
il est clair que le contexte au pe
contre pe a été déterminant et nul ne
sait si à terme il n'y aura pas d'autres
projets de réorganisation
même si on doit revoir notre conflit
armé à ce moment là nous sommes armés
maintenant parce que nous avons une
confiance en plus en nous pour essayer
de faire prendre en compte nos positions
au niveau du social dans l'entreprise
lundi les salariés voteront la reprise
du travail une grande fête est prévue
dans la soirée le préfet du cher décide
la fermeture d'un centre de vacances
organisé par l'association des cadets de
france et d'europe proches du front
national pour justifier sa décision
le fonctionnaire fait état d'infractions
graves christophe devals embrasse alain
darrigrand l'un des derniers salut au
drapeau pour les cadets de france et
d'europe
vendredi le préfet du cher a décidé la
fermeture de leurs camps de vacances ils
nous répondent pas aux normes en vigueur
médicaments périmés
dates limites de consommation dépassées
sur certains produits
les infractions graves aux règles
d'hygiène alimentaire et sanitaire pour
le directeur indignation le camp et
privé peut pas dire que schalke lui
des gens qui ne nous donne pas un rond
monsieur le préfet représente al arab
lui qui ne vous donne pas un sens très
bien prétendre que c'est un challenge
insalubre est mal encadré ici les
anciens s'occupe des plus jeunes monnaie
courante chez les scouts
les cadets sont bien reconnues par les
scouts et guides catholiques mais pas
par le ministère il y a six associations
affiliées au niveau national dont ils
ont des dérogations sur donc les
conditions d'hébergement le camping
peuvent avoir un encadrement mineurs
donc là c'est une association qui n'est
pas affilié et donc fait le régime
général des centres de vacances qui
s'applique régime général non une
sanction idéologique selon le directeur
du camp roger holeindre un membre du
front national proche de jean-marie le
pen
les cadres du parti était d'ailleurs en
réunion aujourd'hui dans ce château sur
le site même du camp pour eux cette
fermeture est une manoeuvre politique du
ministère pire une manipulation
idéologie faux répond le préfet tout le
monde est logé à la même enseigne
c'est je n'ai pas à prendre en compte ce
genre d'éléments j'ai à prendre en
compte la sécurité des enfants sécurité
santé des enfants et surtout des mineurs
et c'est ce que j'ai fait
si le camp veut ré ouvrir l'an prochain
il devra donc tout simplement se
soumettre à la réglementation en vigueur
le tour de france à plus de 50
kilomètres à l'heure l'américain
armstrong a remporté sa quatrième
victoire d'étape dans le contre la
montre qui avait lieu tout à l'heure cet
après midi près de poitiers
il a conservé à l'arrivée 9 secondes
d'avancé sur le suisse double victoire
en vue pour le leader de l'ugt et
postales christophe duchiron il ya 30
ans l'astronaute neil armstrong avait
rendez vous avec la lune
cet après midi lance armstrong le
cycliste avait rendez vous avec le
chronomètre du contre la montre
vous me direz c'est plus terre-à-terre
57 km à vélo sur le circuit du
futuroscope à côté de poitiers
puissant rouleur de mécaniques emprise
du prologue l'américain remporte un
troisième succès d'étape puisque au prix
d'un bel effort plein de panache
eelv a devancé le suisse alex tulou de 9
secondes joue lui a les dents du bonheur
deuxième de l'étape par la même occasion
il prend la deuxième place du classement
général à escardines pour le contre la
montre n'est pas plus family cas corrida
il n'empêche l'espagnol fait un très
beau troisième du tour de france selon
l'expression consacrée richard virenque
qui a tout donné
il a fait tout ce qu'il a pu mais
aujourd'hui c'était loin d'être assez
trente huitième de l'étape à 5 minutes
48 du vainqueur
l'homme aux petits pois sur le maillot
passe de la 5e à la 8e place du général
et pourtant au terme de la grande boucle
le voilà meilleur français à l'arrivée
populaires comme au bon vieux temps
comme si rien ou presque n'avait changé
au fil des jours nous avons retrouvé la
confiance la bonne ambiance de ce tour
tel que nous l'aimons à la présence du
public extrêmement réconfortante car le
public nous a fait savoir qu'il aimait
le tour de france par sa présence par
ces banderoles par ces merci et nous
terminons nous terminons à paris soulagé
et heureux on peut le dire
lance armstrong sur le pod salué par sa
maman et son petit drapeau
demain si tout va bien vainqueur du tour
de france
un américain à paris la culture arc qui
se déroule chaque année se veut une
course de l'amitié et de la jeunesse
chaque bateau doit avoir un équipage
constitué pour moitié de moins de 25 ans
une centaine de navires de 19
nationalités sont au départ au large de
l'île de bréhat
olivier piou michel hiver dire que la
cutty sark est partie bride abattue ce
serait exagéré
il y avait à peine un poil devant ce
matin au large de bréhat pour le départ
de l'armada et les voiles largement
déployée n'ayant pas changé grand chose
on a donc fait du bord à bord en
attendant que le dieu eole daigne se
manifester l'ecosse terme de cette
première étape est encore loin
hier à saint-malo il y avait en tout cas
du monde pour voir les concurrents
passer les écluses du monde et quelques
envieux qui aurait volontiers pris le
départ de cette course de prestige qui
depuis 40 ans dit le règlement
permettent aux jeunes de toute nation de
faire la course ensemble à la voile et
de promouvoir un idéal de compréhension
entre les peuples partout et ça donne
envie de sortir aussi bas on se posait
la question plusieurs moments mais comme
on n'a pas deux fois une heure change
rien c'est non parfois autrement barre
je crois qu'on sera déjà parti oui et
bien pas cette fois ci en tout cas et
pourtant jusqu'à hier il y avait encore
de la place du côté français des
équipages tricolores qui en plus se
comptent sur les doigts d'une main
à croire que les gaulois pourtant venus
en masse applaudir l'armada n'ont pas le
pied marin
on aime la voix le spectacle mais on
n'est pas un pays de marins c'est bien
dommage et
et les gens
vienne voir des beaux bateaux mais il
faut qu'il sache qu'on peut naviguer
dessus et à des coûts très intéressant
et que c'est super quoi qu'il en soit
ici la compétition et secondaires à
l'arrivée au danemark le vainqueur élu
par ses pairs et l'équipage qui a le
plus contribué à l'amitié entre les
peuples
au fait la queue this arc tire son nom
d'un voilier de légende devenu au siècle
dernier
le clipper le plus rapide entre londres
et sydney mais ce n'est peut-être pas
cette fois ci que l'épreuve pulvérisera
ses propres records fin de cette édition
merci de l'avoir suivi je vous en
rappelle les deux principaux titres les
obsèques des scènes de auront lieu
dimanche après-midi à rabat en présence
de nombreux chefs d'état étrangers de
bill clinton yasser arafat de jacques
chirac à ehoud barak
la transition se fait apparemment dans
le calme mohamed 6 succèdera
officiellement à son père après un deuil
national de 40 jours qu'à 14 paysans
servent ont été assassinés vendredi soir
au kosovo au sud de pristina la
communauté serbe accuse les albanais la
force multinationale
le tribunal pénal international
diligente une enquête dans un instant la
météo de patrice drevet il fait beau
suivi de l'émission de jeu fort boyard
dernier journal l'édition de la nuit eve
m'étais demain à midi vous avez rendez
vous avec géopolis le magazine que vous
présente claude sérillon et son équipe
pour un spécial cameroun
je vous retrouve pour ma part pour
l'édition de 13h excellente soirée à
tous
sur france 2
toujours